welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we're hosting webinars
every Tuesday my name is Adam - shuk I'm
a product manager on Google slides today
I'll be talking to you about tips and
tricks to boost productivity in Google
slides in this webinar we're going to
walk through the process of creating a
presentation I'll be highlighting
features and slides they can help you be
more productive you can ask questions
throughout the webinar on the platform
we have Googlers on standby to help
answer them let's get started
presentations are a staple in many
business settings when done right they
can help tell a story they can captivate
persuade and inspire although they're a
powerful tool they can take a lot of
time to put together fortunately Google
slides has several features to make the
creation of presentations more efficient
in this talk we're going to walk through
the typical life cycle of a presentation
we're going to talk about getting a head
start
the collaboration features at Google
slides how to put polish on your
presentation and presenting your final
presentation typically it's best to kick
off the workflow using existing
information or templates to get a head
start and after getting started you will
likely need to work with your teammates
and stakeholders to get all of the
necessary information and collaborate on
building the presentation but before
finalizing and presenting you want to
add an extra level of polish to make
your slides look on-brand and
professional and finally you share out
the presentation or present it in person
while I go through the presentation I'm
going to highlight how Google slides
saves you time during each of these four
steps getting a head start let's
about how to start a presentation if I
were to pull the audience right now
about how they started putting together
their last presentation the majority of
people would probably say they started
by making a copy of an existing
presentation then cleaning up all of the
old content and replacing it with new
content although this is a very common
practice it's not the most efficient way
to make presentations a better way is to
maintain is to maintain clean templates
with placeholders templates save time
and are in they're important tool for
most businesses because time spent
recreating files in the workplace takes
away from the time your team has to do
more creative work however finding those
templates across a large company can be
time consuming and often impossible to
help with this Google slides offers a
template gallery that makes finding the
right template easy because it can be
customized for your company with unique
templates created by your employees with
the template gallery in Google slides
companies can distribute their
up-to-date templates and group them by
team or purpose a template that's custom
to your team will give you a head start
so you can focus less on formatting and
more on driving impacts and developing
the right content for your audience with
Google slides templates you can also
create presentations that scale we
talked about starting off a template and
customizing it to produce your end
result but what if you need to produce
ten of these slide decks they all need
the same formatting but have slightly
different content and certain job
functions like sales this is a very
common workflow the sales associate
needs to have the same pitch back that
they tweaked slightly for various
customers this customizations not fast
and often prone to human error you make
a copy of the template change the name
of the customer the corresponding data
and then you do that one slide deck at a
time
over and over again Google slides has an
API to help streamline and error proof
this process Google size offers both a
REST API and Apps Script API to give
users programmatic access to create and
update presentations in sides from any
data source your team can build ready to
go presentations to turn business data
into presentations and streamline the
slide creation process with these API is
you can use your internal tools
templates and your customer data to fill
in placeholders across various versions
of the pitch deck of the pitch decks you
need with just one click
while templates give you a head start
with formatting and layout what about
getting a head start on the content in
your presentation to help ensure you
always have the most up-to-date content
we built a feature called linked slides
we built this feature because we know
convincing and powerful presentations
often have data and slides from other
sources and we have feedback that this
is a common workflow for many of you you
have a few slides from old decks that
you want to reuse in a new presentation
over and over again but repeatedly
copying asides from one presentation to
another as they get updated is a major
time sink and can be easy to miss subtle
but important changes now with linked
slides you can link and sync slides from
multiple presentations you know they
need updated because in the right-hand
corner you'll see an update button this
way you can maintain a single source of
truth and update content in new
presentations to match your source of
truth with just a click of a button
this can be great for important
presentations like quarterly business
reviews we also expanded the same
linking functionality to content within
slides
we know that a lot of business data
lives in sheets so we expanded the
slinking functionality such that you can
also link tables and charts that you
copy over from sheets files when the
table and sheets is updated or the
corresponding chart is updated you'll
see that same Update button and the
right-hand corner of the table or chart
telling you that there is new data to
pull into your presentation if the
original Charter table changes without
link without being a linked it can be
tedious and time-consuming to replace it
in each and every file this feature
saves you valuable time and we make it
possible to update your chart with just
a single click without the need to ever
leave the context of your document or
presentation now that you have a good
starting point with a consistent format
and slides charts and tables linked from
your previous work you're ready to bring
in your teammates to get their insights
and feedback let's see how Google slides
can help you collaborate Google slides
keeps all of its content in the cloud
this means that there is no need to
create multiple versions of dex emailed
back and forth between teammates with
confusing version names like v 1 v 1
point 2 v 2 v 2 final we've all seen
these and it can be confusing to know
who updated what and when syncing the
content from multiple people and
multiple versions of files can be a job
in itself with Google slides the whole
team works from the same file with
real-time collaboration what you see on
screen is how collaboration works in
Google slides multiple people are making
changes in real-time and even if they're
working in different time zones in
different parts of the world you don't
have to deal with version roulette
because everyone's working on the same
file
but collaboration slides is more than
just content on a presentation comments
and slides also allow your team members
to leave suggestions or notes on what to
edit or add you can also assign an
action item to someone by mentioning
their name in a comment and checking the
action item box the assignee will get an
email and the next time they enter the
file they'll see the action items
clearly highlighted with a blue bar this
allows for clear task delegation and
faster teamwork that's because all of
the collaborators know who needs to
contribute and where their contributions
are needed we also know that teams are
often working on the go while commuting
to the office or on business trips to
help accommodate this we continually
invest in our mobile apps to make sure
you have access to all the functionality
you need wherever you are our apps are
available on both iOS and Android and
the same real-time collaboration
features along with all the formatting
and content creation tools you could
need to create a quick presentation make
a minor edit or respond to a comment our
mobile apps also have some unique
functionality that's optimized for being
on the go you can sync presentations so
they're available on the app while
offline and use the mobile app present
mode to turn your phone into a
presentation remote apart from
collaborators we know that stakeholders
and approvers are often part of the
process to create a presentation you
often need to get your presentation
approved by stakeholders and various
functions like legal and PR the
combination of Google slides and Google
Drive can help with this without G suite
you would probably download the
slideshows of PDFs then use project
tracking tools to collect
formal approvals and sign offs well that
would technically work if any of the
approvers asked for a change in the
presentation you would need to produce
new copies of the files or PDFs and
resend them for approvals as I said
earlier version roulette isn't fun for
anyone with G suite this approval
workflow is a whole lot more streamlined
we recently announced drives upcoming
document-centric workflows feature which
will allow which will allow users to get
formal approvals on their files with
this feature you can submit slide decks
for approval from specific coworkers
upon doing so the file gets locked and
shared and sent to the approvers after
the file is approved it stays locked if
someone looks at the file after it's
approved they'll be able to tell clearly
it has been approved and that's the
final version this lightweight workflow
tool can powerfully streamline company
processes and will soon be available in
an early adopters program along the same
lines when you have many stakeholders
and collaborators it can be really
helpful to track their progress with
other legacy presentation tools after
you send your presentation to a teammate
you have no idea if or when they looked
at it it can be hard to understand who
has seen what and this can slow down
team work Google slides now offers the
ability to view collaborator activity
the activity dashboard allows you to see
which collaborators need your slide deck
and win giving you the power to track
progress on the project with many moving
parts you can find the activity
dashboard in the tools drop down in the
main menu with this tool you can
understand which of your teammates have
seen your latest revision and who needs
to be pained to stay in room
what's the core parts of your
presentation like the message data
visuals are already you start worrying
about the fine grained details the
polish that makes your presentation feel
feel professional and tell the story
best for your audience
Google slides have some great tools to
help with this as you and your
collaborators add content you will
likely need to rearrange the layout of
your slides with the power of machine
intelligence we built the Explorer
feature in slides so you can just drop
your content on the slide and with a
couple of clicks you'll have slides that
look so good people will think you hire
the design agency for them we match
slide themes and layouts to best fit
your content there is no cropping
resizing or reformatting required this
Explorer tool is so compelling because
it really does save time by taking away
mundane formatting tasks we've seen that
people who use Explorer to select their
layouts save over 60% of the time that
they would have spent formatting so even
if design isn't your expertise rest
assured the slides can help make sure
you have a beautiful presentation to be
proud of and although slicing floor is
great it needs you just to supply the
content and we know that another problem
in creating presentations is finding the
right visuals or stock photography that
help deliver the message to your
audience
luckily slides has a platform to help
with that in Google slides we have a
feature called add-ons to help you
source these high-quality visuals from a
variety of sources previously I spoke
about a pis app script is one of these
and it's an open platform that allows
any developer to create and publish
add-ons that can be added to site I
added two slides as a result we have a
rich add-on store with a variety of
functionality
in the add-on store you can find tools
to help you build more powerful
presentations these add-ons can enable
you to source beautiful full-bleed
pictures use advanced formatting tools
or include diagrams you created in
programs outside of G suite for example
you can search for you can search for
and add pictures from Adobe stock right
in slides or you can use the
Shutterstock add-on to add custom adding
customized photos within slides teams
can benefit from even more powerful
capabilities and slides with additional
add-ons from balsamic lucidchart
pear deck noun project and unsplash
these tools help bring your content
that's external to slides directly into
your G suite workflows Google slides
also has several native tools to help
with the polish you need to get your
deck just right one of the areas we've
been focusing it is increased font
support we know fonts matter there are
some fonts that are good for documents
that are read on a personal screen while
others are good on the big screen and
different fonts can really help you
define that the tone and narrative of
your presentation today in Google slides
you can choose from over 800 fonts
appear the more fonts menu in this menu
you can preview our diverse catalogue of
fonts which supports 62 languages
including non-latin scripts like
Cyrillic in the vendor gari
once you find fonts you like in the more
fonts menu you can add them to my fonts
list and once they're in your my fonts
list you have quick access to those
fonts in the font drop-down another
great native design tool that Google
slides offers is the slide master this
is an advanced feature that allows you
to control all of the information about
theme layout
background color fonts and positioning
of all the slides in your deck
using the slide master it can be an easy
way to perform bulk updates in your
presentation or to ensure new slides
always have the right starting point by
using the slide master you can make sure
the default fonts colors and
placeholders on your layouts are always
set up to look great helping you create
professional presentations quickly it's
also agreed to use the slide master when
creating templates for your company that
you'll then upload to the template
gallery that I mentioned earlier while
the slide master is great for making
wide-reaching changes we know that for
certain slides you care about each and
every pixel aligning an object or a text
box perfectly it can be tedious li can
be tedious and difficult so Google
slides offers rulers as well as static
guides to help with consistent placement
and alignment throughout the
presentation you can turn on reversing
guides in the View menu once they're on
you can right click to add new guides
and drag guides to the exact location
you need them to be the guides will show
on all of the slides in the presentation
so that text boxes and other objects
will snap to the location that you care
about and you can ensure that they're
all aligned across all of the slides in
your deck now that you and your
collaborators have added all of your
content and data gotten the approvals
needed and everything is polished and
button up you're ready to present your
work whether you're presenting from your
mobile device or your laptop be edgy
sweet neat or on the big screen to
present your view in Google slides it
gives you as a presenter a special view
into the presentation the presenter view
helps you be a better presenter with
features like speaker notes quick slide
validation and a laser pointer
speaker notes allow you to craft your
message and have access to all the notes
you need to give a great presentation
right at your fingertips our quick nav
ik navigation tools and presenter view
allow you to quickly navigate to any
slide in your deck if you need to
revisit a specific point or visual and
at any time you can turn on a laser
pointer to direct your the attention of
your your audience to a certain part of
the presentation
in presenter view you also have access
to a feature unique to Google slides Q&A
with Q&A you can better engage your
audience by allowing them to submit
questions and vote on them during Google
slides presentations once you start a
Q&A session
Sly's displays a unique URL that
audience members can go to and submit
questions you can decide when to answer
the questions and display them right on
the big screen one by one the audience
members can also vote on the questions
other people submit so you know where to
focus your time if you only have a few
minutes for questions this concludes the
journey of a typical presentation I hope
you learned some about about some size
features you may not have been aware of
and as a quick recap slides helps you
get started with tools like templates
and AP is and facilitates real-time
collaboration with comments and action
items you can let slides for your
personal designer with slides Explorer
and finally you can have confidence with
slides to help to help you that help
give you that the power to give a great
presentation and host live Q&A with an
audience if you want to learn more about
Google slides you can visit the G suite
Learning Center that's a wrap for today
please stay tuned for a live Q&A we'll
be back in less than a minute
you
welcome back we have a couple of
questions from the audience that I'd
like to answer the first question is
after final creation can Google slides
work in offline mode that's a great
question the answer is yes in Google
slides you can make it all of the slides
files that you want available in offline
mode and when you make changes offline
as soon as you go back online those
changes will be synced to the
presentation with all of your other
collaborators the next question is can I
share a presentation I make in slides
with someone without a G suite account
yes there are actually a couple ways you
can do this
in slides you can share the present view
of the slide deck and make that public
and this allows you to share the content
of your presentation with whoever you
want there's also ways to download the
content from slides into multiple file
types like PDF or PowerPoint the next
question is how can I prevent someone
from making changes to a presentation I
send to them and how do I limit access
to a presentation so only people in my
company can see it these are also great
questions and important ones so when you
share a presentation in Google slides
you have the option to provide different
levels of access you can provide access
to edit access to comment and access to
view if you provide access to edit the
collaborator can change whatever they
want and decide with you if you provide
access to comment they can make comments
on the side but they can't make any
changes and if you provide access to
view the recipient can only view the
contents of the deck there's additional
advanced settings in the share menu they
can even prevent you from letting people
copy contents from the slides to other
decks in terms of a limit of access to
presentation so only people at your
company can see it there are the main
level controls at the admin level that
can be set so presentations can only be
available within your domain can I add
videos to my slides as the knife slash
question
this is also a great question and we
have two ways to do this
you can embed videos directly from
YouTube into your deck and you can also
upload videos from Drive that you may
have saved from a variety of sources
into your deck and the last question is
can I hide some slides when I'm
presenting this is actually a feature we
just recently built and it's called skip
slides when you're in the the Edit view
of slides on the left hand side there's
a filmstrip and if you right click on a
slide in the filmstrip you'll have the
option to skip slides if you highlight a
slide and select skip slides you'll see
an eye icon and that means when you
present that slide will be skipped it
looks like that's it for the questions
so in closing you can stay tuned for the
next session
how nest uses a Google cloud and tableau
to drive its business thank you very
much for your time
you